Trascrizione: Federica Bruno
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che cosa c’entra il DNA con i viaggi?
Provo a spiegarvelo.
Sappiamo che la scoperta del DNA
è un evento straordinario
per molti motivi:
non ultimo, perché ci ha permesso
di mappare i viaggi
sin da quando l'uomo
ha iniziato a spostarsi,
dall'Africa centrale,
dove la nostra specie si è manifestata,
fino agli angoli più remoti
del nostro pianeta.
Abbiamo così scoperto che le migrazioni,
i viaggi e gli spostamenti
sono la caratteristica più comune
ad ogni essere umano.
Siamo gente che si sposta,
e che si è sempre spostata.
Oggi la fotografia
accompagna i nostri viaggi,
ed è un modo per condividere l'entusiasmo
per ciò che si è visto e vissuto;
all'inizio si va alla ricerca
della bella spiaggia,
bei panorami, bei monumenti:
ad esempio, ecco il mio
primo viaggio in India
dove sono andato alla ricerca
dei simboli tradizionali del paese.
Poi, però, succede
che si finisce attirati
da un mondo così diverso,
che per quanto uno provi a descriverlo,
non si riesce proprio a rendere l'idea.
Ma è proprio qui che qualcosa è cambiato.
Sapete quando si dice
che ciò che rimane veramente,
del viaggio, sono le persone?
È vero, perché sono quelle
che ti rimangono dentro:
e quelle mi sono trovato a fotografare
cercando di catturarne
l'essenza, lo sguardo.
Vedere dentro gli occhi di chi ci guarda
crea una connessione intima
con la loro vita e la loro storia.
Ma non sono certo bellezze da cartolina:
sono bellezze diverse, più rare.
Ci sono tantissimi modi,
per raccontare queste persone;
Io ho scelto di raccontarne la bellezza.
Ho scelto di trasmettere lo stupore
che provo ogni volta che viaggio,
condividendo la più grande ricchezza
degli esseri umani: la diversità.
(Video)
E se ci spingiamo sempre più lontano,
ci si ritrova tra popoli e etnie
a noi sconosciuti.
Bisogna però riuscire ad abbandonare
i propri stereotipi, le proprie abitudini,
per riuscire a calarsi completamente
nella cultura che si incontra.
La scelta di mostrare queste persone
attraverso una forte componente estetica
è perché penso
che la bellezza sia la chiave
per far avvicinare
sempre più persone a questa realtà;
e attraverso la condivisione
dei miei scatti,
mi sono accorto che funziona:
le persone si incuriosiscono,
e hanno iniziato a chiedermi
dove sono questi luoghi,
come sono queste persone.
Quindi, la fotografia aiuta a trasmettere
i mille modi in cui la bellezza si mostra.
Quando si scatta un ritratto,
si instaura quasi come una relazione
con chi sta dall'altra parte
dell'obiettivo.
Che essi siano uomini, donne,
bambini, anziani,
ci si ritrova a comunicare
anche senza una lingua in comune.
Possiamo dire, quindi,
che unendo viaggi e fotografia
possono nascere amicizie
che sembrano improbabili.
Che cosa abbiamo in comune
con un santone indiano,
un pastore afghano o una contadina cinese?
L'umanità.
Scoprire che abbiamo tutti
le stesse esigenze,
anche se le manifestiamo in modo diverso.
Oggi la modernità e l’interconnessione
tendono a renderci tutti più simili,
riducendo la diversità.
Ma esistono ancora gruppi, popoli, etnie
in grado di raccontare
il loro legame con il passato,
anche se questo è sempre più raro.
C'è chi conduce ancora
una vita completamente nomade.
Chi sceglie di abitare
le zone più impervie del nostro pianeta.
Chi abita in case senza elettricità,
o senza acqua potabile.
Dove il fiume, il sole,
la terra, gli animali
sono ancora, da sempre,
l'unica fonte di sostentamento.
Ma sono mondi che stanno scomparendo.
Per questo penso che siano
da vedere e da raccontare,
perché il rischio è che di loro
non si sappia neppure che sono esistiti.
e sarebbe un peccato,
perché sono parte di noi
anche se non li conosciamo.
Proprio per questo, viaggio dopo viaggio,
ha preso corpo un progetto
senza che neppure avesse un nome.
Possiamo chiamarlo "Atlante dei popoli",
che non è altro che la raccolta
di tutte le culture presenti
sul nostro pianeta.
Ci sono tanti progetti
di questo tipo nel mondo.
Mi fa piacere citare quello
di "Atlas of Humanity"
perché sono stato uno dei primi
fotografi ad esserne coinvolto
dal suo ideatore Martin Vega,
alcuni anni fa.
"Atlas of Humanity" è un progetto
che riunisce un centinaio di fotografi.
Che lavorano ognuno per sé,
ma con l'intento di documentare,
attraverso le proprie fotografie,
la diversità nel mondo.
Ho aderito con grande piacere,
perché in fondo il mio percorso
mi stava già portando
alla realizzazione di un mio,
ideale, Atlante dei popoli.
Vi faccio qualche esempio.
La tribù Ch'in in Myanmar:
Vivono nella giungla,
al confine con il Bangladesh,
Il loro fascino sta nei tatuaggi
sui volti delle donne.
Ormai questa pratica è stata vietata,
quindi è sempre più difficile
incontrare giovani donne
con questo antico ornamento.
La tribù Kayan, sempre Myanmar.
Qui le donne, sin da giovanissime,
mettono collane ad anelli in oro e ottone
aggiungendone una anno dopo anno,
fino a raggiungere
questo collo lungo e affusolato.
In realtà si tratta di un effetto ottico,
perché non è il collo ad allungarsi
ma le clavicole ad abbassarsi.
L'etnia Miao in Cina.
Qui le donne mettono
questo caratteristico copricapo
fatto da una grossa matassa
di fili di lana
intrecciata con i capelli
dei loro antenati.
In questa zona della Cina, le popolazioni
sono particolarmente ospitali.
Mi è stato chiesto spesso
di entrare dentro le loro case,
per mangiare tutti assieme.
Il popolo dei Nenet,
nel nord della Siberia, in Russia.
Abitano la penisola dello Jamal,
e sono nomadi che vivono
di pastorizia e pesca,
vestono con queste pelli di renna
per difendersi dal gelo
che può arrivare anche a meno 40 gradi.
Ho vissuto nelle loro tende,
chiamate chum.
Qui si mangia e si dorme tutti assieme:
genitori, nonni, figli,
e pure con i cani pastore.
Dato che il loro lavoro è molto complesso,
non mi è stato chiesto di aiutarli.
L'unico compito che mi è stato dato
è stato quello di tenere vivo il fuoco,
e di rendere confortevole
la tenda al loro rientro.
La tribù dei Bakarwal,
in Kashmir in India:
sono pastori nomadi,
che spostano gli animali
lungo gli impervi sentieri himalayani.
Una delle loro caratteristiche principali
è la barba di questa
tintura fiammeggiante.
Con loro ho vissuto una migrazione,
e mi è stato chiesto
di aiutarli a seguire il gregge:
un po’ per mettermi alla prova,
ma sicuramente anche per farsi due risate.
Vi assicuro che non è stato
proprio affatto semplice.
I monaci tibetani nella valle
dello Zanskar, in India.
Siamo sempre sugli altopiani himalayanI,
dove ho avuto la possibilità
di entrare in un monastero
ed assistere alle loro pratiche religiose.
Qui i bambini studiano
per diventare monaci;
ma come in tutte le parti del mondo,
ecco un pallone, e la vallata
si riempie di risate.
I pastori Waky, nel corridoio
del Wakhan in Afghanistan.
Qua siamo a 4000 metri
sui monti del Pamir.
I Waky mi hanno accompagnato
passo per passo
in questo territorio impossibile.
Mi hanno insegnato
dove poter trovare acqua potabile,
come accendere un fuoco per cucinare
e dove posizionare le tende per la notte.
Senza di loro mi sarei sentito
sicuramente perso.
Questi sono solo alcuni esempi,
ma ecco perché tanto impegno
per raggiungere luoghi così remoti:
perché è sempre una grande emozione
raccogliere queste testimonianze.
Ormai ovunque, anche ai confini del mondo,
la modernità e la tecnologia
stanno arrivando
e i giovani stanno abbandonando
le vecchie tradizioni.
E così mi sono chiesto:
ma saremo gli ultimi a vedere
quelle donne dai volti tatuati,
o quei pastori di renne
che vivono tra i ghiacci?
E poi, che cosa accadrà?
Da questa riflessione,
l'idea di utilizzare la fotografia
come testimonianza.
Ecco lo scopo più grande:
far capire quanto il mondo
sia variegato, ricco di diversità,
e quanto poco sappiamo
di quello che ci circonda.
E alla fine, abituare gli occhi e il cuore
ad aprirsi alla diversità
può aiutare a capire
che la bellezza della diversità
è davvero ovunque, anche a casa propria.
Da qui il mio interesse, insieme
alla società sportiva "Prima Gioco",
a far nascere un progetto
a cui tengo molto.
Si chiama "Basket Inclusivo".
Qui i bambini giocano in gruppo
senza distinzione di maschile, femminile,
normodotati o diversamente abili.
Tutti collaborano al gioco:
ed è un modo per far vivere,
sin da giovanissimi,
la ricchezza e la bellezza
della diversità.
In conclusione, mi sento di dire;
appena possibile, torniamo a viaggiare.
I viaggi non sono solo belle esperienze:
i viaggi offrono qualcosa da imparare.
Quando si torna a casa,
ci si sente cambiati
non solo nei pensieri
ma anche nella consapevolezza del mondo.
La diversità è bellezza, arricchimento
e la conoscenza apre le nostre menti
ed espande gli orizzonti.
(Applausi)